so i was like okay um where's the
mouthwash
[Music]
so this comes from the h3h3 podcast all
right they were covering the story they
brought on a guest this woman went on a
certain podcast and then had a story to
tell afterwards she says she doesn't
like the people she met there they gave
her a ride home and she leaves her
wallet inside the vehicle i left my
wallet in myron's car because he was the
one driving and myron gets the wallet
and walter was like oh he wants your
friend's number if he's gonna bring back
the wallet meaning me
so
i was like um sure like i need my wallet
like i'm not gonna text this guy anyways
um he gets my number and he brings back
the wallet and i had basically texted
him saying like don't steal my wallet
like before he put it back and then he
tried to maintain a conversation with me
like through text and i was like
not answering him because i had gotten
my wallet back and i only had about like
three more days i i had left in my trip
and me and my friend were saying like
you know it would be fun to sit here and
like
make him look dumb like he sits here and
he thinks that he can get all these
women but then a 19 year old like
doesn't like you know like um rejects
him
so
um basically he he kept like texting me
every day like when i wouldn't respond
he would just say hello hello hello like
called me i never answered and then
eventually i was a little desperate
and then i was like you know if i'm
going to hang out with him like i'm okay
to hang out with him to like because you
know like you can't interrupt him on the
podcast but i can interrupt you at
dinner so i basically said you know what
um yeah if we're going to hang out i
want to eat dinner or go to lunch simple
and he said well you can come to my
place and see if you can handle me
and
i was like no he said if you can handle
this from there he just basically just
kept texting me like
does this make story this does this make
sense story to you
that's okay
no no no no no no like this was so
[ __ ] nonsense you say okay he text me
nonstop i don't respond
cool
then you say but you know what actually
i'll go to dinner with this guy so i can
interrupt him so i'm like you know if we
go to dinner i'm fine with it then he
keeps texting me but i don't respond
does that make sense no whenever someone
comes to me with a story like oh this
dude shady i'm like
what's your style what did you do let's
hear it and i'll i'll try to listen to
you and if your side of the story which
i know is supposed to favor you doesn't
make sense i'll look at you a little bit
yeah definitely every day like um if
we're gonna go about can izzy and walk
so
can my friend and walter come and she
and he was like oh well you can't leave
your friend alone and i was like
not really because it was because i
never wanted to be alone with them at
all i did not want to be able to say and
me and my friend had gone out to the
club that was like around like around
her area
and when we went in there we were we
were doing our own thing and walter had
showed up and he came up to us like we
went to his table he was talking to us
and he comes straight up to me and he
says
oh myron wants you and i said
a child
like
on the podcast i was sick to my stomach
just being on the podcast itself
but um
like just being in his presence like
later in the night i felt very sick
because it was just weird i also tried
getting myron out to the club so again
like i didn't want to be alone with him
oh stop stop stop stop okay my girl
miguel
miguel
okay
why are you going out with a guy that
you don't want to be alone with
who raised you and what are you doing
why why why
because she wants to be the one that
rejects him i really really
that that's ego that's ego as much as
this [ __ ] got ego you got ego
you need to get checked girlfriend why
you want to go in a place
you put yourself
oh my god if that was my daughter i
would be like
with your stupid ass
why do you put you go out of your way
just because you want to prove a point
cause you got ego
that you're gonna try to spend the night
with someone you don't want to spend the
night with
so while my friend was like oh yeah
that's great let's get food with each
other and walter looked over and like
signaled her like no like we're not
doing that
so eventually like they pull up into we
pull up in front of the podcast
apartment and myron's coming out of the
building and i get out of the car and
walter leaves
so now they've left the club with them
to go meet up with the dude that she
supposedly said she wanted nothing to do
with and really disliked no you're doing
the most culture leaves with my friend
and took her
so
i'm with my room by myself so he we get
into his car and he drives us this story
makes no sense so when your friend was
in the car with walter you get out the
car whether he just drives off with her
like a hostage situation is that what
you want me to believe and then you
being terrified in [ __ ] downtown
miami all right where there's people
everywhere you were just like all right
i'll get in the car with this dude that
i don't like why i think it's kind of
creepy and weird
really this is the story we're supposed
to believe does this make sense to
anybody listening and what about the
friend is a friend just looking sitting
there like with a gun to her head i
believe what would you say happened
happened
okay because
because of when i was working with in
social services and stuff like that blah
blah blah
they act like that who's they the girls
that age
they act like that they really do
now it's not because she did act like
that and that story didn't go unfo it
probably unfolded the way she says it
unfold but my girl
this is on you
but it's on you girlfriend just to be
clear when you say it happened like that
you're not saying that it was this weird
creepy thing you're just saying that
the girl
she thought it was creepy and still went
with it that's what i think i don't know
i don't buy that i don't buy that
i think this is a whole [ __ ] lie it's
a work
this is how dumb this whole thing is
it literally can't be possible for
someone to say this goofy [ __ ] and it
happened the way that they claim you
don't text a guy but then you make plans
with them then you never want to hang
out with them but now you want to reject
him
no no but what i'm trying to say is
there's a light somewhere
ivory
i agree
this doesn't make sense there's a lot
she's like there's a lot but if it
happened the way you happen it's still
your fault remember when we covered
remember when we remember when we
covered that thing about aziz i'm sorry
and you told me that yo and i i asked
you but though aren't you gonna wait
till you see aziz's side and you said
well
her side
her side doesn't make sense right if
this is your prosecution and your
prosecutor i don't even need to hear the
defense because the prosecution doesn't
make any sense well your honor when i
killed the man so you killed the man
case closed yeah
you killed the man you're talking about
it's like this like
place this spot i don't know why it was
open at 5am but
he um
we sat down we ate food and mind you
from the minute why was it open at 5am
because it's miami stupid so let me get
this
oh my god your friend gets taken away
okay then you get in the car with this
guy y'all go get some gruff because you
know what i mean even though you get a
kidnapping you still gotta eat me so you
know
i mean yeah i mean being a victim makes
you hungry i have a sense of kill that
you know i if you want money i don't
have it but if you want food we could
pass by
at any point you could have called your
friend at any point you could have just
left hey this is not arkansas okay this
is not some [ __ ] place with no cell
service this is not rural florida where
gators everywhere this is downtown miami
if you don't want to leave with the
[ __ ] call a [ __ ] uber
it's not that expensive it's out of the
car to the minute that i left
with him i was debating him the whole
time and not even debating just telling
him how much i hate his views and like
him himself
and
yeah so basically my friend was alone
with fresh and i was alone with fit
jesus perfect night i'm talking to him
i'm facing him in the driver's seat i'm
still going i'm passionate and heated
telling him my views and stuff and we
ended up back at the podcast studio
what is you doing
hold
i don't want to be alone with him so i
don't go to the studio oh my god oh
my god
i'm still going i'm passionate and
heated telling him my views and stuff
and we ended up back at the podcast
studio we were going at it we were
arguing we were fighting about this and
that and then all of a sudden
you know we were [ __ ] and i don't
know how it happened
that's what it sounded like we were
going back and forth it really makes me
think of like magenta lamar's song
when at the end it goes [ __ ] you [ __ ]
[ __ ] you [ __ ] [ __ ] you [ __ ] yo [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you [ __ ] me it went
yeah
[Laughter]
four or five a.m in miami and like no
one's in the studio but the lights are
all on they have everything set up and i
already have like i already knew the way
of the apartment so i'm sitting in the
kitchen area of the podcast studio
i'm walking out to the balcony and
there's like a door that i hadn't seen
open before like basically it's an
apartment that they made into a studio
so that was the bedroom so i'm walking
like towards the bedroom into the
balcony like towards the balcony and
he's standing in the door frame and he
just grabs my face and kisses me wow
there you go hebrews reading the room
good at reading the signal you talk
about oh he couldn't read the room
you went back to his place at five after
he told you you should come back to my
place and see if you can handle me
i like how she just skips over the parts
where she can explain things like oh we
were arguing and we were passionate and
then i was in his apartment so then i
started walking through what the [ __ ]
how did you make that leap can anyone
explain the sequence in this [ __ ]
story no it's like watching a m night
shyamalan movie it makes no sense this
happened and this is low budget and
night shyamalan he's been telling you
you claim okay i'm not saying your side
you claim he's pushy he constantly tells
you he says i want to bring you back to
my place so you can see what i can
handle it's 5 00 am he picked you up
from the club took you back home
separating you from the girl every
indication said that y'all was [ __ ]
tonight
and then you guys want to say if you
couldn't read the room why the [ __ ] are
you there
oh but you can't ask that because that's
victim get the [ __ ] out of here bro get
the [ __ ] out of here man that is the
most privileged position in the world
where you can walk through life and
think you can make the most crazy
crazy decisions after being told this is
what's gonna happen you come back my
place we gonna make out we're gonna [ __ ]
you just know all this you show up
you're like whoa
he tried to [ __ ] me
i know he told me for the last hundred
times he was gonna try but he really
tried it
and
kisses me i i i'm like no think like you
know i'm like no thanks did he lead with
tongue or no
irrelevant
this is how you could tell that he's
inclined to not get laid much or he's
never really dated much who asked that
[ __ ] question
objection did he put a finger in your
bum like uh when he made out with you
did he grab your hands at the same time
how did he do it did he lead with tongue
who the [ __ ] asked oh my god this is
like the other dude was like who's your
mom yeah this is the same dude
let's not relive that moment so i just
pushed him off and i was like oh i'm
just going to go to the balcony and he
goes
you need mouthwash
yeah what yeah i said i was texting my
friend the whole time you see me say
like he just told me to get mouthwash or
something let me pull up this text
again guys we have receipts this is
fully vetted bro mine just grabbed me to
make out and he goes get your listerine
you taste like alcohol
no he obviously knows you came from the
club he's disgusting so i come back in
the room and then i go to the bathroom
like in the kitchen he's like that's not
where the mouthwash is so i was like oh
okay um where's the mouthwash
[Music]
oh
we need to fix things we need to fix
things
we need to fix things bro are you a
little scared at this moment
i was very uncomfortable and
also i always forget this part whenever
i tell a story but like but a little bit
beforehand i had opened the fridge
before like he kissed me and stuff i had
opened the fridge and i saw like he had
white claws like because they have like
alcohol in the fridge and stuff and they
have they had a white collar on the
fridge and i was like oh white claws
like oh can i have one like as a joke
and he was like yeah you can have one
but just don't tell anybody because
she's underage
so i was like he tried to give me
alcohol no no no no no no
no
no no i want everyone to remember no two
things you were at the club and your
girl said when you told your girl he
told me to get listerine or whatever
because you were drinking cause she what
does she reply she says oh it's because
you can tell for your breath that you
were at the club meaning you were
drinking at the club nah and now you
want to act incredulous no we're not
doing this bathroom um i'm standing in
the bathroom like trying to kill time
again like with it on the balcony when i
come out he's like laying on this bed i
come back out and i was wearing like a i
i was wearing a fresh hoodie and if you
don't
get the [ __ ] out of here now
now you're just doing this [ __ ] on
purpose my g you just want to trigger
the [ __ ] out of me now you're just
[ __ ] playing with me now you're just
[ __ ] playing with me that's what the
[ __ ] you're doing now i know how the
[ __ ] you're going to edit this [ __ ]
you're going to put a whole bunch of
smiles
bro if you don't get the [ __ ] out of
here hey man
i was wearing
oh my god bro i can't make this up let's
keep listening my girl she was wearing
freshly fit gear
bro bro bro
let's go let's see watson he goes better
i i was wearing a fresh hoodie and
because
they have like a room full of merch but
i asked them where does it go they say
nowhere so they all just collectively
wear fresh and fit like all day long you
filmed that yet no no no hold on hold on
hold on how are you going to try to talk
[ __ ] about what they wear on their lap
[ __ ] you wearing it
yo yo you guys are such losers for
wearing this
you know how much a [ __ ] loser you
are for wearing this shirt that i'm
wearing right now [ __ ] you a fan
he's a fan yeah i didn't have the keys
to my friend's apartment so i didn't
feel like going like taking an uber
there and just waiting
right so
i'm like trying to like you know again
like
give him cues like i want to leave i
don't want to be here and he's like oh
you can sit on the bed so i sit on the
bed and i'm sitting at the edge of the
bed you know like the memes are they so
i like how this he tells you hey can you
sit on the bed fine you're trying to
give cues that you want to leave at what
point did you make this clear to him
i'm just asking at what point did you
tell him that you wanted to leave and um
i'm sitting at this edge then he's like
oh you know you can come up a little bit
more so now i come up but i leave a nice
gap between the both of us where it's
like very obvious like i don't like you
that i'm it's very obvious that you
don't like him but you do what he says
so he even even did a mouthwash so so
your indication of saying you don't want
anything intimate or physical
is
sliding up exactly as he told you he
kissed you you didn't like it he asked
you to put on my smartwatch you did
okay let's keep do you see how that can
be perceived as someone saying okay i'll
put mount wash for what you to continue
leaving a gap between us
and i'm on my phone he's on his phone
and i remember again i was speaking
about my views once again he just jumps
on top of me and starts making out with
me
like like trying to kiss me and stuff
and so i'm like i have my hands like on
him where it's like i don't want him
like laying on me like intimately so i'm
just holding my hands up and i'm like no
no no
this was about like
max a minute long and i was wearing like
this shirt and it's like a very loose
shirt whatever
and he basically lifts up the shirt and
made a comment and then i was like i'm
done i'm over this like he lifted up
your shirt and kind of looked at
underneath it and commented yeah yeah my
chest and it was very creepy
so i i i don't want to uh
this
this is
a bad this is very bad
i think he may have assaulted you i mean
at this point i
yeah i i mean i don't want to say that
but like again like
i don't want to say that but that's
someone i'm going to let you make your
assumption
that's what you are employing when
you're telling this whole story and then
that's what he's trying to push like
yeah he did this terrible thing it was
it was very quick so i was just like no
like right away in my head i was like no
i don't want to have like sex with this
person like i don't
right away in my head
in my head in my head so this is the
[ __ ] right yeah she's telling this story
the way she's narrating she's narrating
her thoughts yeah
[ __ ] the other person across from you
can't do the thoughts no what did you
actually say
so i like as soon as he like makes that
comment i push him off me and i say
i i verbalized to him i said i don't
want to have sex with you he got very
mad like he just got mad like he just
like he did like a little toddler thing
where he was huffing and puffing went
and goes on his phone and he just like
went silent and i was like okay like i'm
and i changed back into the outfit that
i had in the bathroom and i came out i
give him the merch back and i say okay
can you bring me home now
and he said
no i parked my car already
so
i was like okay i'm gonna order my uber
now and he was like okay like just
acting like a complete
yes it's not his duty to bring you back
home the entitlement on this is amazing
you came to his place at 5 00 am okay
made
the most mixed signals i've ever seen
and by all indications looked like you
guys were gonna [ __ ] then you said no
last minute okay you want to leave okay
give me a ride no
why does he owe you that
you could say he's an [ __ ] you can
say it's a douchey thing we agree
why is this a youtube video an actually
who gives a [ __ ] if the main is douchey
why is this a youtube video the reason
why you're airing this out is to paint
them as some kind of [ __ ] predator
that's why you're doing this so let's be
honest the reason why this is being
framed this way okay this is a regular
encounter where the dude's mad they're
not getting late he says leaf
who cares
he was just a dick you could have had
some you said no
he acted like it who cares and the funny
thing is that
actually when you actually verbalize the
note
he stop
you have no story there bro that's not a
story the minute cuz every from every
every every point that led up to this
you did everything that he asked you to
do and when you said no he stopped this
ain't no story i order my own uber
and i'm walking out and i'm like oh my
my uber's coming like can you walk me
downstairs because i didn't know how to
work this building so he walks into the
elevator pushes the button and walks
away like with no did you want a good
night kiss what is it
what did you want uh a shake of hand can
i just appreciate wow
can i just appreciate this guy made me
uncomfortable
he made moves on me and i didn't want it
i didn't like any of it and at the end i
was like can you give me a ride
yeah
and i get into my uber and like at that
point i think that's when it kicked in i
started crying because i was like i
don't know what just happened but i feel
uncomfortable and i i that's where you
could read the rest of the messages with
my friend because i mentioned everything
in there you started crying
uh i don't blame you that the whole
thing is really traumatic and i'll tell
you what i actually didn't know how
how crazy this story gets at the end i
i'm sorry you went through that
it's all right i just want to bring you
more i mean wow
the thing that's really crazy is like if
you're hanging out with somebody
you know you don't always have to give
someone a ride home
but what's messed up is
they intentionally split you guys up
and then he took you all the way out to
the studio
and then basically stranded you there
he's like well if you want to leave you
got to [ __ ]
stranded her
how
you could have just left you could have
done at the beginning what you ended up
doing at the end was just calling an
uber
you chose to get in his car you chose to
go with him and get some food you chose
to then argue with him because you
wanted to make a point because whatever
ego blah blah blah then you chose to go
up to his apartment
at which point were you held against
your will at which point was someone
pulling you anywhere
you wanted this
and now you want to sit there and be
like oh my god these guys are so bad you
know the problems with this kind of
stuff
is when you guys use these kind of shady
tactics to try to take people down or
whatever the [ __ ] it is it just
emboldens them it emboldens them and
bolders their fan base because like look
at these people
trying to take them down with lies they
must be doing something right and listen
these are absolutely nonsensical stories
that these people are peddling the fact
that h3 is platforming this person and
not even questioning any of the lies
that they're seeing is mad to me
it's crazy
not only that they're doing it for a
financial game because they hate these
guys they'll just
hey man you got a story on them let's go
you got to scrutinize this woman
because what she's saying makes no sense
anything you want to say
uh
listen lady
what you're doing right now is a
disservice to real victims that's what
you're doing yep and every time they're
gonna tell their story they're gonna say
the real [ __ ] that happened people are
not gonna take them seriously because
they're gonna think about you because
you have a platform it's already hard as
a victim to come out and be like this
[ __ ] [ __ ] happened to me
and then you pulled this [ __ ] off
these kind of encounters okay where
people get together try to hook up and
one person another one they just leave
happens every single day all the time
it's nothing to post about it's not a
big deal
sometimes two people think listen nobody
can sit there that if they heard just
the facts of this story she was going to
his place at 5 pm they'd been talking he
made moves on her you wanted to
basically indicate to her that he wanted
to hit it she goes there nobody would be
surprised if the dude made a move and if
you said listen she went there at 5am
and she said no and she's like she just
ended up leaving people like i could see
that happening this is a regular thing
but they put this out there and they
framed it this way because they know
that they can make anything like this
look awkward and uncomfortable and
creepy and whatever at the end of the
day i'm not a fan of stories stuff like
this i think this is incredibly bad
and uh i think content creators have to
be more responsible on their platform
these people not to just do this whole
[ __ ] [ __ ] of like believe women
no
because guess what
people lie they're liars men lie women
live everybody [ __ ] lies
just inherently believe people
because when it's gonna be your turn
and you like that's some [ __ ] you're
gonna wish some people actually had some
scrutiny for the people who are accusing
you you made me defend this
dude no
at the end of the day what we defended
was a principle it's like if you lied
you lied yeah you like i don't care if
it lies against somebody i don't like
yeah you lied you lied